[Music]
welcome back to the gentleman podcast
aka Bunny's favorite time of the week
it's the bunny out she doesn't haul ass
quite as fast - any room in the house as
she does to the podcaster I don't know
why though like what is it I don't know
anyway guys this episode is brought to
you by the farmers dog is what we feed
our three little babies and they love it
as dog food made better than the others
okay board certified veterinary
veterinary nutritionists approve the
food that you're gonna feed your dogs
with farmers dog it is a really awesome
service go to the farmers dog calm sighs
Jenna Jillian get 50% off your first two
weeks check it out marbles eats it
terminates at peach eats it peach tries
to eat Kermit marbles that's how much
she likes it also guys thread up is the
other sponsor today it is an awesome way
to get up to 90 percent off of retail
brands of clothing thread up is an
awesome secondhand clothing service that
you go to thread up calm thre DUP comm
slash annejulien you'll get an extra 30
percent off your first order when you
sign up with that URL check it out
there's a lot of really good [ __ ] there
like design or [ __ ] okay I promise it's
their go to look anyway we haven't put
him on his invisible perch yet I don't
think the side table I was gonna use is
tall enough we need to make it higher
okay we can make it higher or what is he
doing he wanted a hug I don't know why
now though I don't know he just wants a
hug he's my boy you can get a hug if he
wants yeah okay all right well that's
that I guess
yeah marbles isn't floating yet I know
you guys want him to float but I think
we should do is make it so this is like
his magic carpet so he's floating on
this and then nothing below him so he's
just like right up here real high up
might do it he probably wouldn't mind
he'd like it I mean he liked flying up
in the air with balloons
he doesn't mind do you think do you
think he wants to go back up there
should we do that again I don't think he
knows where he is
this morning I was talking to Jenna and
I was leaving the I was like walking out
of the bedroom house it's like talking
her and I'm standing in the doorway and
marbles is like rearing his his head and
his neck for battle and he's like his
eyes are getting wired he's like shaking
and Jenna's like Daddy me fight my god
when you fight a flight at you dad
cuz he got up and you don't know who
that is now five minutes after he feed
you breakfast with the farmers dog and
you forget you forget I know I don't
blame you I don't blame you you're
looking handsome today he's looking
handsome today
he's always handsome have we talked
about bunnies discovery on the podcast
yet what discovery what are you the ear
the birthday oh I don't know we haven't
talked about that I don't think so okay
can I tie go ahead okay so I was a we I
was doing research on bunnies your
tattoos
the Greyhounds get tattooed on their
ears for their registration number and
also their birthday and litter number
it's a way for when they race for them
to kind of get them in the system and
keep it organized the whole thing anyway
when you see a greyhound likely they'll
have tattoos on the inside of their ears
and there's numbers in each of their
ears and I was I was misguided at the
beginning I forget what or who or how I
was thrown the wrong direction but I was
interpreting the wrong ear for the
birthday so her left ear says six eight
one five five I thought that meant
because I was directed to believe this
six is the month eight is the day one
five is the year six eight one five was
her birthday and then five means she was
the fifth in her litter that's what
those digits mean makes sense make sure
we got her she was three years old
which is a weirdest coincidence right
okay yeah and and then you know right
here you could see three six six it
turns out it didn't say three six six in
a right here I was looking really
closely cuz it's kind of like fuzzy at
this point you know she got him when she
was a baby and they they like crimp them
on with this like press so it doesn't
you know it kind of fades a little bit
and it says three six G I was like
really studying it and I was like you
know what it's weird because the what
made me learn that it wasn't a six as
the second digit was how they gave the
tattoos it's not by hand it's unpressed
so there wouldn't be any deviation and
how they do two different sixes they
should look exactly the same and since
the second six was like a little bit
rounder and bigger I was like wait
that's a G so then I did some more
research I was looking and looking I was
like hold up hold up hold up this is
three six G and I learned that the
birthday is that here so three means a
month six means 2016 they don't give the
day of the month the one before the one
before that you know we can assume she
wasn't born in 2006 she wasn't born in
2006 we know that well I know that cuz I
looked up how they code the birthdays
and it's like if it was three five or
three four it would have been 2015 or
2014 and then G is you count down from a
in the alphabet and that is the number
she was in her litter so she was the
seventh in her litter cuz I said G
litter but she's you're younger than we
thought she was
we already celebrated her fourth
birthday on June 8th as a Gemini but G
girl was born in March we know what it
is bunny is arey you know what it is
she might Aries girl we think I mean
well we decided we decided I mean I
think greyhound owners as well as like
dog owners who adopt and maybe don't
know the exact birthday of their pet
they choose a day right like they just
pick a day yeah yeah what 25th March
25th well so we celebrated her 4th
birthday because when we got her we were
told she was 3 which was true but that
means we got her in like April or May we
got her name she had just turn
three she was like literally three like
right before we got her yeah she was
like we got her a month before she would
have been - right well we thought she
had been three for a whole year and then
the next month in June it was her fourth
her fourth birthday so we celebrate her
fourth birthday when it was in actuality
not even her birthday so this March it's
gonna be your fourth birthday again but
it's so funny that we made this
discovery because she acts like she's
younger a lot of her makes so much more
sense it makes so much more sense a lot
of her personality of like the
uneasiness if she's in a room alone
she'll cry she'll just baby she's a baby
she and we you know we we always gave
her as much room as she needed as much
slack as she could potentially use
because she's our girl and we want her
to be happy no matter what but it does
make more sense that now that we know
she's younger because she does act a bit
younger and I think as she gets older
you know it'll start making more sense
when she's actually four will be like
okay she's behaving like she's four not
like she's three cuz that's a pretty
significant difference in the age of a
dog cuz especially a greyhound because
especially with these guys like like you
said they don't calm down till they're
way past like traditional puppy age yeah
well to me I feel like a dog will just
in my experience a dog really starts to
mellow out a little bit after they're
three years old yeah yeah like for all
the people that are like my dog won't
even like look at me when I talk to them
because they're just they only care
about their toy or whatever I'm like
just wait till they were like three or
four and you know they really start
actually responding to you and listening
to you although I mean it's not true of
all dogs yeah but for me personally
peach had like boundless energy until
three you know she was and like Kermit
really started listening outside and the
whole listening you know responding yeah
yeah you know yeah I would I would think
like her confidence is the biggest
indicator of her age she's a still a
little uneasy about herself she's not
very confident Oh bunny bunny and three
years old makes a lot of sense anyway so
we thought
she was four and a Gemini she's three in
an Aries so nice is so funny we already
so sorry
we already celebrated her fourth
birthday and she's like a random day she
was like yeah it's my birthday okay she
just had like a dull past day in tune
for no reason she deserves it but now
birthday month isn't the only month of
the year with birthdays for the ducks we
have two birthday months and it makes
more sense as she's an Aries cuz she's
just like you she's a little tornado she
is a tornado and he's like I'm chilling
I'm chilling I'm chilling I'm out of my
mind yeah and it also sheds light on our
strong bond Aries bond full life you
call a tornado see my Aries girl anyway
super [ __ ] interesting development I
think well cuz you looked it up because
I would I would just been like ashes for
ya I'm trying to I like forget there was
some sort of piece of information we
were given or someone we talked to her
that was like yet left here was this
little right here means this and so now
we know that our left here 6a 155 that's
her registration number so that's not
even birthday but she didn't race she
didn't write that was her number if she
was gonna race yeah they registered them
before they actually no yeah which one
was gonna race him which one's not gonna
race but anyway our girls a little Aries
and she's gonna have her second fourth
birthday it was so funny I was like
sitting in the game room and Julian just
comes in he was like Jenna I like what
he's like 23 are you talking about she's
four you're like no she's three he had
her birthday wrong and I'm like oh my
god what have we done how it's wild and
like you said it was the weirdest
coincidence that her the her she was
three when we got her six eight one five
right it fits into that same year anyway
Phil probably we had to update you guys
on that we already told stream but it's
it's just a funny thing I don't I just
think it's so cute like I don't know in
your mind when your dog is like okay my
dogs for hmm but it's so cute that when
we got her she like was - basically she
was kind of a baby
big big baby he's a big baby she's such
a big baby she's like she's happy energy
yeah yeah oh that's so funny I got so
many kisses today like she's being baby
mm-hmm
she is baby she's baby that's funny
baby well I wanted to play a quick
little game this is the second time
we've done this you guys seem to like it
the first time we did it I don't know I
don't think I liked it well they did so
that's all that matters oh no deal with
it I'm embarrassed
this is quizzing Jenna on her own videos
part 2 do I do well the first time you
did I believe you did really well
I believe you kind of surprised me to
the point where I was like wait I
surprised me because when I make videos
a lot of times they're just like in and
out of my brain you know yeah but I make
them I post them yeah and then you know
I don't go back and watch my youtube
library of myself
you don't go watch your YouTube library
of yourself no you don't go to social
gatherings and chromecast your own
videos we usually have our rules don't
don't oh speaking of putting content up
we got an Apple TV finally and I can't
tell you how much I love that thing
holy crap that thing is cool we've never
had Apple TV you got it so we could
watch the fight because we've been
watching fights in buffer buffer ring
for how long now well we bought
chromecast's like four [ __ ] years ago
and the moment we bottomed our like
everything chromecast we got to get one
in every room it's amazing all you do is
press a button in your phone easy right
mind you there was even back then a much
better solution called Apple TV that we
never bought but basically yeah we would
we would buy the paper view to a UFC
fight on our phone
then we'd chromecast a TV and because
our phone had like worse Wi-Fi you know
signal than an Apple TV a dedicated
device or whatever
it would be buffering every 30 seconds
the fight and we're paying 65 bucks for
a goddamn fight that it's buffering and
we're just like this is our own damn
fault
yeah totally can we come over and then
we're just like sorry it's just
buffering during every punch it's like a
three-second pause painful right and
then four more punches and then a
three-second pause I'm like I wanted to
die so bad and like we have we have bad
internet but there's no changing that
cuz they have a monopoly on our air we
can't upgrade so I figured let's get an
Apple TV we can watch the fight through
that so I got the Alba TV download the
ESPN app we watched the whole fight zero
lag completely crystal clear all night
it was amazing but I discovered all the
things you can do with an Apple TV you
can screen share from your phone you can
just throw a video up yeah when Julian
showed me that and I was like oh my god
now we can finally just sit in the
living room and watch take talks on the
TV you can sit the living room watch tic
TOCs on the TV and all like all the
times when you know i'll be preparing
for a flight or a long trip and I'll
rent a whole season of a show on iTunes
for my iPad and I never watch it you can
watch it on the Apple TV now
everything's linked it's amazing I don't
know I don't know where everyone is
probably like yeah we've been new I
[ __ ] all of our friends have
been telling us to get it forever - yeah
when you don't listen when you don't
listen all right you ready to start this
yeah so I think all these are your he
doesn't see my handwriting pretty neat
right I hand rub these do you see this
she's sitting like stacked on top of him
and they're both just like completely
fine with it yeah she's like getting a
piggyback ride right now all right this
one is me talking in your video this is
my line wait so what are these these are
just random quotes from videos
throughout the last probably year or two
year - yeah I went through the last
couple of years I didn't want to go
super early okay um and I'm gonna read
you one quote this is how it works I
read a quote from one of Jenna's videos
completely out of context and you have
to guess which video it's from okay
right and and you know bonus points if
you can tell me the context
okay ready and I'll I'll give some time
for our friends to play along yes you
guys play along at home okay this is me
talking this one is my line mm-hmm
prepare to be turned on okay that's so
obscure no no no
prepare to be turned on all right so if
I had to guess the context would be I'm
doing something to you where you are
looking very hot you know is it the is
it when I gave you a pin-up girl what uh
how do you guess that I just explained
my reasoning but you said you dude you
do things to me all the time and videos
that was just one example I looked
dashing in so many areas I mean it was
done solely it was a guess well you
guessed it right it was the pin-up video
thank you
were you prepared Fran turned on it was
gonna make you honestly know I don't
think anyone was I don't think anyone
was ready for that sexual energy that
you just exuded with that wig and that
makeup and that but yeah well I really
liked how I gave you that outfit to put
on and you came out and this shirt was
like all the way up and like I'm just
kind of feeling myself I've never been a
pinup before oh you're so cute
all right that's fun we had a great day
that was you know watching these back is
fun because a lot of the ones that you
know and we're doing stuff together or
whatever like it just reminds me how
much fun they were like even though
there's like the stresses of filming and
all that that we had a good time we had
a good time I did okay this is you
obviously the rest of them are you
should I at least pour out some of my 40
for it I'll read it again should I at
least pour out some of my 40 for it so
honestly something obviously something
happened not in my favor and it probably
for lack of a better word died and I am
my respects to it if I had to guess I
would say it's like something I failed
at so um or yeah well the the time that
I did all the fingernails on one thumb I
had alcohol or at least something in a
champagne glass
is it that one no okay is it the time
that I covered my hand in paraffin wax
no good guesses though okay I don't know
maybe they say the answer I don't know
well how does the game I'm gonna give
you another hint okay okay you you said
do I should I pour some out for the
homey or whatever for the you know for
the lost whatever but you're harder on
yourself than everyone else so it may
not it might not have been a complete
failure okay that's not helpful okay
it was the one you made a wig Oh God oh
that was a good wig you made I was just
somebody like tweeted at me or something
today they were they had a picture of me
in that wake from that video and they
were like you know that that hair is
really expensive so if you don't want to
waste it you can always just unglue it
and then glue it into your head as
extensions and I was like girl my hair's
like down to my butt right now and not
orange and that's I'm gonna do in some
tracks that are about this long and
orange so they'll barely show no no no
it's like me putting in the yellow
extensions now but yeah I don't that
it's still really fun it's sitting on
that like styrofoam head we have
downstairs yeah it looks good
I like I don't think they're wasted
there I like how you made that way
because the concept of making a wig is
cool you take someone someone else's
hair or hair that has been recycled
right and you bring it I don't think
that's the process of knowing how do you
know no it has well it's recycled if
it's used prior and then it was used by
someone else okay me me halfway here I
don't want to get into the ins and outs
of the hairy one also is recycle comes
from but okay what also is recycled is
the clothes that you can buy on thredUP
Wow just like a wig if you guys go to
thredUP you can get some amazing used
clothing and you're shopping more
sustainably by doing
you're helping the plant okay and you're
also at the same time getting really
awesome deals on really awesome clothing
I actually don't know anything about
wigs I just use that as a means to an
end there so if you guys enjoy Nike
Lululemon Theory any of the top brands
that you guys usually dread about how
much they cost and you don't want to go
shopping or worry about paying a lot for
it but you still love them go to thread
up and just check it out they have a
really great selection of all the brands
that you already know you like and you
already know fit you well and a lot of
them are in really high-quality great
condition
barely worn sometimes and you can update
your wardrobe at a really really
reasonable price which is a really good
thing about thredUP so when you go to
thread up thr edie you pee comm /
annejulien
today alright now open up a new tab or
something you get an extra 30 percent
off your first order when you use that
URL I think it's a really cool idea and
they do a really good job of it you can
find some really cool [ __ ] it's like
going to a awesome yard sale but it's
online you don't have to drive anywhere
does he just what he's probably thinking
about dinner I'm gonna farmers dog
farmers dog is a way to treat your pets
your loved ones to the best possible
high grade delicious food that they can
eat if you have a picky eater and a dog
and you know they're like like marbles
you know doesn't really want to eat
sometimes it's very like you know
finicky if you try to feed him stuff
that you get away with some cheap stuff
no he's gonna pick up on it he's a
texture guy he's a texture guy he needs
some high-quality [ __ ] what you do with
farmers not easy go to the farmer's dog
calm /schedule and click the link below
and you fill out a profile for your dog
what they like to eat what their eating
habits are how big they are what breed
they are how often they eat / per day
things like that and what farmers art
does is they formulate this plan this
meal plan I mean they they eat better
than we do they have a [ __ ]
nutritionist making them meals that's
the dream yeah they formulate this meal
plan and they send you easy to open and
use packages
of fresh dock food for them and it is
amazing it's so convenient Jenna doesn't
have to sit right next to marbles while
he eats anymore it's a dream go to the
farmers dog calm slash annejulien th e
fa RM e RS do g comm sausage annejulien
50% off your first two weeks when you
use that URL check it out awesome
service we use it all the time the end
where will you see yourself what you see
he's so cute
you see greatness he's like kind of
looking at that direction he was already
yeah we're taking a walk on the art wild
side just call me an art rebel so this
was either acrylic pour or the other one
that we did with the knife let's is it
from let's abstract paint or let's
acrylic pour no okay sick but you're
very close I yeah very close we do
another one do we do Bob Ross no it's
not that
you're getting colder warmer earlier I
think we actually did use acrylic paint
for this but it was a different tool is
it a hydra dipping crock
no could guess stuff okay i don't know
paint with string yeah that was the
title of the video right I paint with
string let's paint with let's play with
string yeah I like I like your your
quotes when you're doing like arts and
crafts that they're always really funny
like what like that I'm an art rebel I
like that I don't know probably it's
funny at all yeah but you're you
I mean I'm a lot of thing that's funny
that's funny that's fair all right great
this is a good quote right here snatch
me like one of Liam Neeson's daughters I
think that was recent
I think I was doing ok so I definitely
used the word snatched on ironically in
the video where I was recreating who to
beauty's tape because she said snatched
like a thousand times and nothing but
the tape lift yeah nice cuz I don't I
don't just like walk around things
that's to really know you you kind of
take on part of the personality of the
person you're washing in the tutorial a
little well she just kept saying snacks
you're gonna be snatched you're gonna be
so snatched no it's like whoa that we
amuse these daughters one of them
there's one of them just the one that
keeps getting absolutely [ __ ] rekt
it's naturally like her okay when you
get cuffed at the LACMA give me a second
all right where's the moment police what
were we doing okay
this was when we made advent calendars
for our dogs nothing but net yeah easy
nice I was trying to remember when you
said that cuz it was like semi recently
and we were painting like at the table
and I'm like what we're repainting
oh just admin calendars for our dogs
that I still thought that was so funny
oh that's a dog what do you say mo MoMA
I made like a play on words with MoMA
yeah that was a good one I was cute ha
Bobby we actually pretty much kept up
and gave them treats every day until
Christmas that was fun well they really
liked it it was really cute all right
this one is a conversation I'll read
your line than my land wait how Italian
are you me how can you be okay we were
cooking and it's pretty recent try to
think of what we are cooking
because you actually edited that video I
did because you were like I'll edit this
for you and I was like wait it was a
collab and then you actually edited it
for me I was like thank you I mean I can
tell that I didn't edit it personally
because I edit things differently hmmm I
can whatever we're cooking we cooked Oh
God
I mean reason again whoa are we cooking
something Italian we were making Italian
weddings - thank you you got it nice I
love while you're making faces behind my
back I'm not making face Barney Rach oh
my eyes widened cuz it's difficult out
of context no you were just so close are
you kidding me you you're destroying you
haven't even got one wrong you got one
wrong I have a pile of dogs that's a
self-inflicted thing okay sometimes
trying to open your tiny mind is
exhausting okay that sounds like
something I would say to marble and was
I trying to get him to sit mm-hmm okay
was am I saying it's a marble mm-hmm
was I saying it's you know you're seeing
it like we're talking Torah clay yeah
basically saying don't be [ __ ] closed
mind like a non-existent imaginary
person who's being close-minded was I
talking about take talk oh no okay no um
I don't know okay this was the rap which
video oh this was the I want a new face
I it was somewhere in there where you're
putting on the prosthetics and you talk
about like how you look different than
people's expectations or something good
Oh sometimes trying to open your tiny
mind is exhausting you're saying it to
no one I see yeah but that's a good
guess that you would say that the marble
because we do say that because he does
have a tiny mind yes Daymond and it is
hard to open it little ass mind okay
why does everyone else's look good and
mine looks like I got hit by a bus
sounds like I was doing something to
myself in the beauty department accurate
and I was trying to do something that I
saw on YouTube so fake freckles nope
closest [ __ ] though I know exactly how I
said that too
mine looks like I got hit by a bus about
what would you say that about makeup
Wow I'm drawing a blank I have no idea
hair braiding Oh God
oh those braids Oh God you did good in
that one what do you mean oh they just
like don't look good on me and it's sad
and you look so cute in that video hello
I mean I know you don't appropriate here
I know we're friends but you look you in
that video friendzone me done you know
what's so frustrating to me well it like
actually makes me feel a little better
is that when you see all those like
pretty Instagram pictures of braids and
you're like oh my god that looks so good
yeah I love that
yeah I've seen pictures and videos of
people you know when they just turn
their head around and you see what it
looks like
on a human being like with their face
showing it looks like garbage on some
I'm like that makes you feel better is
it's just a picture of the hair
Instagram is fake everything pictures of
the hair it looks amazing but like in
practice like in reality it's not it's
all an illusion I doing it no not doing
it alone
not different to him ok this is a pretty
textbook Genet quote I'm really scared
but excited because I know that there's
no rules but I'm also overwhelmed by
choices that sounds like something I
would say about art correct that's a
curly pore yes holy [ __ ] nice well done
thank you that is a very very Jenna
quote right there overwhelmed by choices
I get really easily overwhelmed by
choices like when we play Detroit become
human it's a very overwhelming game for
me it's complicated moral and ethic
questions that are not easily answered
fine you have to respond quickly to
which is like the hardest thing I have
to do you know mm-hmm
make difficult decisions quickly that's
not how my Virgo brain works I need a
lot of time to weigh out the options and
think about everything no just make a
decision no it'll be over and then
you'll forget about know make a decision
snap snap snap
sorry this isn't nice and pleasing like
the videos this is violent this is real
life kind of profound okay so I was
following a tutorial with some sort mmm
I'm inspired by videos of people doing
something I said it's violent it's a
real life this is violent this is real
life can you read the beginning yeah
this isn't nice and pleasing like the
videos this is violent this is real life
yeah that was when you were cutting soap
to make a soap bed oh god oh oh my god
are dead smell we did that like a month
after moving over this house
and it made our house smell like soap
for weeks oh my god everything smells so
strongly of soap it was awful our fridge
every time you opened it it was so
intense it was so intense and he didn't
even like it no you say no to him so he
grabbed it please okay this is another
really good quote this is a banger this
one says I guess I'll just take a lonely
adults hour now oh okay so I was
definitely in a messy pickle curve I
just told you lay down honey
so something that was like very involved
so I either made myself into a chair or
I I think this is turning myself into my
green screen no it was chair
damn but you're a [ __ ] no you're right
on there though it's one of the videos
where you get your whole face yeah disco
ball Weiss what can you answer me is it
disco ball
what was I turning myself into Carmen
like why are you doing that just looking
at I said I'm gonna I'm gonna go take a
lonely adults hour I'm gonna take like a
juvenile shower lonely adults hour now
that's just such a funny whine like a
lonely adults hour I've taken a lonely
adults hour pretty much every day you
know it's like I guess there are
different types of showers aren't there
oh never thought of it as a lonely
adults hour until it came out of my
mouth yeah we yeah and now it's out of
context so you really have to delve deep
into the mindset of where you were
Kermit your wolf he didn't he's he needs
a farmer's dog yeah well he doesn't get
to doesn't just get what he wants okay
this is a good one I think you'll get
this because of how specific it is we
bothered some people in the middle of
the night so it was worth it what was I
doing that bothered anyone in the middle
of the night it was at the end of a
makeup video you did something that you
normally wouldn't do that involved
strangers Oh was I when we used some
omegle or whatever that chat is I was a
spider mm-hmm it was the double-vision
makeup when you went on that random
video chat I was this speeder those
reactions are so good oh man we we went
on omegle first or something right
no just a phone app hmm it was pretty
much Omega with no like chat it was just
facetiming strangers mhm mhm okay
it's not like the I'm Trisha Paytas
crying on the kitchen floor but I'm
trying to get there okay this is trying
what's the best mascara to cry in mm-hmm
legendary video I think you're doing
some good science there I appreciate
some good science and that was good
science that idea came to me divinely
while I was sitting outside thinking
about absolutely nothing and I I was
staring at the sky and I just thought to
myself I want to cry and a bunch of
mascaras but I'm you know not really I
want him to run down my face you have a
very special and beautiful mind I wasn't
trying to think of it you know it just
it just happened okay next one if you
all see me this weekend and I'm just
completely broken out just know that
this was worth it okay something was on
my face that facepaint that disco ball
chair book bang mukbang got choose one
chair no disco ball hmm disco ball and
that was it
did it that stuff is like really taxing
on your face I'm gonna do stuff that is
like that one didn't look fun I neither
did the rhinestones that one looked
painful when you were doing that okay me
all right I'm gonna have to actually
perform this one okay make sure you turn
it make sure you tune in to FM every
Saturday night at 9:00 p.m. we play in
nothing but uh sure I set that into the
go XOR and that was at the end of either
watching tic TOCs with me or meme review
or playing episode are you shaking your
head no shaking my head no but you're
right about the girl are what else did I
do in the gorgs are SM I'm trying to
think of what we
what why why why can't you just like
communicate we want to give sneaky hints
I hate it green-screen that's why we
film down there because of the
green-screen
so I was doing the move bong without my
hand it was at the end when you had
completely [ __ ] lost mind you can say
that and said you're making me feel so
weird when you like glare around the
room I get like it gives me like a pit
in my stomach like something Bad's
happening why does it give you a pig it
just does well I'm sorry I didn't even
give you a pin your stomach thanks
friend stop huh oops laughs stop working
okay Kermit tomorrow's your birthday you
know what that means doing something for
myself this is kind of vague I feel like
this one's pretty tough yeah it's very
hard you already guessed this video for
something else I don't know hide your
dipping number one yeah that's right
before you were enjoying the video okay
next one is it wrong yeah
should it be banished forever yes okay I
know exactly what that is that's corn on
the cob but instead of the corn bone
it's a hot dog you're owning thank you
it should be banished should be banished
I forgot how ugly some of those looked
when we were an abomination it was so
good though it was really good I
genuinely really nice coordinate is
really good okay two more it's good for
your back to have some twists in it
Jenna the doctor I was i doing i okay in
real life I know that whenever we're
sitting next to each other you like go
like this on my chair and you genuinely
twist my spine and it hurts my okay know
where we said no no not next to each
other are our armrest bump and then
you're like my spine broke that's you
that's literally what happens put your
feet on the
my feet are on the ground okay yeah
spine still intact not what happens to
me like genuinely twists my back and it
hurts so bad I'm sorry for feeling pain
I don't know I don't know if we were if
we weren't in our gaming chairs you were
in your gaming chair okay
gaming well turned away from the desk
this was I'm gonna be a ladder for
Halloween dog stairs yeah nothing but
net
but you like how I I knew I was in my
game chair that's that's the time I know
my back is twisting and it hurt maybe
you need a new games you know it's not
the charity it's the man pushing you no
one's listening to me so it doesn't
matter anyway
I'm listening me I am it's just funny
because sometimes I will be playing like
um Detroit or something next to each
other on the computer and I'll go I just
ow my spine is twisted I know but I
don't know your spine it tells you like
I wish my chair so that my back twists I
don't know how else to describe it it
genuinely hurt I don't I'm sure like
spread out like this over the whole desk
and he'll like this much space I don't
I'm not man spreading I'm not man
threading twist my chair my back and
I'll like kick you I'll try like kick
you under the desk and you never pick up
on that you're just like what's up
what's up what's up bid and I'm like
some [ __ ] choice in my chest subtlety
is not my strong suit and I'm not a
man's brother so don't don't give me
that okay what's the last one
oh you just want to get it okay
it's cute but it doesn't mean they play
eSports this is a girl me yeah I just
like that quote play eSports you got
play sports
eSports anyway I think you got like a
90% at least probably an a - its
horrifying how much that information is
just like in my brain I know imagine if
that wasn't in your brain what else you
could be putting in it I could be
putting so much good stuff in my brain
like what anything more ancient aliens
yeah it's a good episode last night
around City House cool let's go
well well
I hope you guys did as good as Jenna it
probably didn't though maybe you did
raise your hand if you got 90% nobody
okay should I raise your hand do you
enjoy doing this it's embarrassing but
sure that's why I like it I'm an
embarrassment you know what I do to
prepare for this like I woke up this
morning I was like oh we're gonna do
this I just literally play your videos
and then I go about whatever I'm doing
and I have my notepad next to me and
something will just be said and I'm like
there we go
you know I mean I just kind of let it go
because you're bound to find good quotes
in your videos if you just let them go
they're good quotes I know you don't
think they are but they're good quotes
do you think mine are good quotes yours
what like what I say in my videos yeah I
think they're bad there you go that's
exactly how I feel hmm Kermit says that
we're done here
screaming all right guys Kermit's crying
so we're done thank you guys for hanging
out for a dog dictates how long your
podcast last sometimes your podcast gets
cut short because your dog's emotions
yeah he is he he went a little crazy
when we were passing around the feelings
box and you could only take one he took
like five had walked into the shower
taking the like cloth the little mitt
that I washed myself with and placed it
on the bed and was chewing on it
ooh you're nasty and you need Jesus he
loved taking that because it smells like
soap he brought it all the way into the
bed so he could chew on it loudly to
wake me up he knows we're talking about
him - he's all self-conscious
all right y'all have a great week we'll
see you next week for another episode of
the generally in podcast thank you for
listening we appreciate and love you all
bye
[Music]
[Music]